it's more about speed and size
uncle will take you home after uncle
i'll see you tonight who is uncle uncle
maya
who's oh
pan up
get out get out
he gets a blue arrow and she gets a
normal play
why shoot up
oh
no way
no way
no stop it stop it
oh my god
oh she killed all those people but it
was so good
oh oh my god oh it was for the fight how
are they still alive
later and this is just amazing welcome
back to new rock stars episode three of
hawkeye not only introduced us to some
cool new trick arrow shots and dove
deeper into maya lopez's backstory it
also left us with questions like who is
uncle the mysterious boss of the
tracksuit mafia and why is he absolutely
wilson fist kingpin
also
where did hawkeye get all those
wonderful toys and if we can't trust a
bro who can we trust what the hawk
this is inside marvel our weekly deep
dive into hawkeye our official hawkeye
after show i'm eric boss i'm here with
mt mt
this episode to me uh congealed
everything i love about this show
this is a this is an amazing show
yeah dude like we just got our first
tease of uncle willy uncle willy is
pretty much i mean it's not confirmed
but come on we know those cufflinks
anywhere that's uncle willie wilson fisk
i'm sorry i mean yeah like when they
said uncle's gonna take you home i'm
like uncle take me
do you make me what you will
what is that suited man doing in the
karate academy
if he's not cavehead i mean look right
talk about it
um
we'll get into it let's recap what
happened this episode so we're
introduced to maya lopez a young deaf
girl but with brilliant observation
skills this i love this little kid so
much she's so sweet
oh yes and like the relationship she has
with her father who is zach mclaren who
has been uh in fargo season two and
westworld he is an amazing actor i love
this guy i love the casting on this show
like this is clearly meant to draw a
parallel or at least a comparison piece
between the introduction of kate bishop
right who is a kid born with a silver
spoon who also has this moment with her
father but like whereas that is just
supposed to meant like a world of wealth
shattered suddenly we have a similar
thing here right where william has some
financial struggles he can't send her to
a deaf school he's like you're just
gonna have to make it work but here's
how you do it uh just like a true
beautiful moment uh and maya like kate
is someone who seems to be groomed to be
a warrior in this world but unlike kate
is really having to work on it she has
to be like an independent person who
does not have a
mentor at least that we know of but it
is clear that uncle served that role to
her and her father served that role to
her that uh that eleanor served to kate
but i think the way that they're both
groomed is just kind of creepy and you
will find out more about that mta you
had some thoughts about this karate
academy right
i love this school
oh yes i mean let's be real everybody
the mcu just introduced the most
powerful character ever ever introduced
in mcu history uh the little brown kid
that uh had to fight echo uh the way he
took down that other kid before echo i
was like whoa
my heart i don't know if i can handle
this much power this boy is powerful
only a yellow belt but uh punching way
above his weight class or way below in
this case however straight he showed
when echo walked up and he was like i
don't want to have to fight this girl
like this kid give him a spin-off
exactly i mean he's only a yellow belt
for mercy he would be higher but he's
just like i would kill everybody back so
i can't go higher than this
that's it
well
maya witnesses the ronin killing her
father and uh she has a vengeance
brewing inside her and we cut now to the
morning after clint and kate's capture
the tracksuits i guess have spent like
six or seven hours just forcing them to
be on these mechanical and give a
relationship advice apparently
what is going on in that back room like
uh echoes like i have to listen to all
six hours of this idiom uh i cannot just
wave off i have a ritual i cannot
disrupt it
yeah those guys seem like laughable like
i just feel like by the end of this
series they're probably gonna be comic
relief and we're gonna love them because
we are i already love them already i
think they're already comic relief i
just want to know why they need to spend
so much time like i think it's like this
card chase scene we could only shoot in
the morning we want to shoot in the
morning that's the only time we could
get the bridge for uh but uh yeah it
just implied they were hanging out for a
while but like didn't beat them up
during the time i i just thought that
was fun um
anyway uh during this point of capture
um echo notices the hearing aid and then
decides to you know uncuff clint so that
he can sign to her but he doesn't know
sign language but i thought it was like
a clever bit of storytelling because now
they re-tape his uh his restraints and
he's able to kind of like you know cut
his way out of it and once he gets his
hands on his bow game over bro
what a delight to see clinton go to town
uh like he's so cool
have we ever seen clint use his arrows
just on people this way like i guess
hydra at the beginning of
age of ultron but they were like in the
distance and he was using mostly
explosive arrows just like plugging
arrows into people's shoulders and their
backs and stuff like it was like
oh yeah like in hey like and clint
himself says that in the episode he's
not really a role model he just he lays
that out straight up because he kills
people he kills people i mean we saw him
do that in end game for sure but like i
feel like the sword was mainly his
weapon of choice in tokyo just seeing
him do it with bow and arrow was kind of
like we need to talk about kevin a
little bit but i i enjoyed it
more of that yeah more murder many of
them died none of them died insanely
none of the track suits he got killed
i don't know all this stuff that was
thrown didn't kate kill like one of
those people like in the in the van or
something
she must have she must have but like no
one seems to be
licking their wounds that much like our
friends are dead like that
just made me think like someone rolled
out of that car at the right at the
right minute the fact that the giant pim
arrow didn't kill
several people on that yeah it's insane
to me it should have took out that
bridge let's be real
the bridge should have gotten taken out
the weight and momentum of that arrow as
it dropped out there's no way at least
one of those suspension cables didn't
pop anyway uh
but this whole chase was just a delight
to watch so good ten out of ten
cinematographers
we love you children have been swivel
cam in the back seat oh boy oh boy we
got to see all these different arrows i
loved it uh now in the aftermath the
episode really just needs to take a
breather it feels like and it does like
the rest of the episode is just people
kind of unpacking what just happened
you know that chase was crazy
cosby warns maya about uncle finding out
about her obsession with hunting the
ronin which is interesting like uh uh
uncle is not sanctioning uh their their
pursuit of the ronin which tells us
something uh clint gets his hearing aid
repaired uh but he still keeps it turned
off when he's talking to kate he's like
another roger's a musical i just can't
listen to it he's like all right more
youths talking gotta turn this off thank
you hate it
uh we get a name for the dog pizza dog
pizza uh we'll see if that's the name by
the end of the series i have a feeling
they're gonna settle on on a different
name um but then they go into eleanor's
flat and uh they go on her computer we
learned that qazi is an employee working
for a company called sloan limited that
is in their database now uh you know the
bishop security has a database of
everybody working for everyone it seems
like like it doesn't mean that sloan is
some shell company under bishop security
but i'm just saying that the name they
had before was a former bishop security
employee and now they know like why
would they know of the employment status
of people for other companies if they
aren't connected to them in some way
um or unless they were investigating
them for some reason it's just slow and
limited we'll talk about what sloan
limited might be but the episode ends
when jack discovers them holding clint's
own ronin sword to his throat
what happens next
um so we're gonna talk about who this
mystery uncle figure is all the kingpin
clues we have seen so far empty and i
are gonna break down uh that sleeve
we're gonna look real close to that hand
listen close to that laugh
we know you guys are
but first our merch partners at epic
hero shop have a brand new latest
obsession shirt inspired by hawkeye and
you can get it at newrockstarsmerch.com
it's a limited edition shirt with a
really cool design it's subtle it's
great it's like the the perfect hawkeye
shirt that i wanted uh you got to get
your hands on it because when you get it
you'll get the added option to write in
a custom shout out that will appear at
the bottom of these hawkeye after shows
leon jackson asks hey eric is there a
chance sharon carter is a big bad behind
the scenes of the hawkeye series
uh there's a chance uh there's a chance
of power broker i i don't think that was
uh emily
but i do think uh that there it's not
definitively kingpin yet there there's
other possibilities of who this could be
and i think sharon carter is at least uh
possibly associated with the people
behind the series um right brit asks do
you think bullseye will return from
daredevil season three in ecco what do
you think about that mt i think it's
possible i mean i i think that you know
well
granted this universe was probably very
much separate from the daredevil netflix
universe so we'll probably just see a if
anything a bullseye variant of um yeah
it would be a different i yeah i think
you're right i think you know netflix
still owns the rights to these shows and
like uh there's only going to be so many
characters who marvel shelled out to to
pass over into the mcu uh or thought it
would be worth it to do and i think it's
most likely gonna be dinofrio and
charlie cox if that even happens you
know hey i also want turk barrett let's
make it happen kevin turk
yeah there's a lot of good uh faces
christine palmer not to mention of
course jessica jones and luke page and
all those great folks uh kai from
scotland asked do you think elena might
join kate and clint in finding the
killer i hope so
yeah i i think elena's on her own
mission i i picture you elena being the
ahsoka tano of this show she's gonna
show up one episode and then kind of
go off on her own path for sure for sure
yeah she's she's gonna probably try to
kill clayton just be like oh no it's a
huge misunderstanding let's team up for
an episode then i alright i'll see you
in a future movie
all right mt let's get into it what's
our big question from this episode well
eric we gotta ask who the hawk is uncle
you know the boss of the tracksuit mafia
who is you know completely we've never
seen this man before what a completely
new cat uncle
unfamiliar i don't know him from uncle
that's for sure
well of course the go-to assumption is
that this is gonna be kingpin confirmed
right
would make us happier to actually get
that right
but
you know the evidence does certainly
point in that direction but we are going
to get to some alternate theories just
in case because i think you can make
some alternate arguments for sure other
than kingpin um but let's you know
remind ourselves what happened maya's
father william tells her that uncle will
bring her home after karate practice and
then this dark suited figure approaches
the sound editing makes his steps sound
additionally heavy uncle will take you
home after class
i'll see you tonight
[Music]
the only footsteps we hear in that
moment not william walking away this big
thick dude
[Laughter]
oh imagine if it's thanos i would cry
laughing
this thanos
yeah
i have to drop by and run a couple
errands first home depot uh is only open
for so long
but then it just shows up in his like
toyota donut he's like
come on
we're going to titan
um
so he pinches maya's cheek he laughs she
smiles up at him uh
many are claiming this is definitively
vincent d'onofrio's laugh i don't know
i'm gonna have to listen more talk show
appearances before i agree to that like
i remember daredevil you know dinaprio
was doing a deeper voice
like definitely when he laughed if he
ever did it wasn't as much of a ha ha ha
it was more of a
so i don't know if this is a dinafrio
laughs hey man it seemed pretty good to
me i i felt like he was here with us a
younger a younger man a 2007 era wilson
fest perhaps talk to me about these
cufflinks empty uh to me
the fact that he had cufflinks was just
interesting it was hard for me to make
out at least before i dive into the
breakdown of this if that cufflink had
any particular design did you see
anything there i i didn't notice
anything super um like interesting about
the cufflinks themselves just like the
whole image of him just cause like he's
standing there in a very vincent
d'onofrio way i don't know how to
describe it but if you've watched three
seasons of daredevil you know how the
kingpin his whole aura is in like that
whole him just standing there even if it
wasn't vincent dinofrio
like the whole the way the suit was
tailored the way it fits on him it's
very key yeah the tailored three-piece
suit yeah i was looking for the watch if
he had that watch that would have been
it would have been
game over this is at least the guy who
you know sent the tracksuits in i think
either way for sure he doesn't want that
watch uncle wants to watch whoever the
uncle is um but let's step back for a
second recognize how weird this brooklyn
karate academy is from the earlier shots
because we see you know maya's father
william revealed to be a track suit here
but there is another track suit that
exits the door and uncle is here for
whatever reason and that kid who your
buddy throws to the floor is credited in
the credits as young quasi that is
causing so i think
it isn't it isn't mentioned in the final
version of this episode but i think
something was cut from the scene or has
yet to be revealed this could be where
maya and qazi met
and for whatever reason a lot of adult
track suits either run this academy or
all send their kids here
i think this as i said was clearly meant
to establish maya as a parallel figure
to kate but with some key differences
both are children whose parents profit
from organized crime we think but
whereas kate got every opportunity to
succeed uh groomed by your mother maya
definitely had more of a struggle um but
might have been groomed in uh similar
ways to be child soldiers to be warriors
for whatever this empire is
i think the tracksuits and uncle are
grooming children of this karate academy
to be warriors and soldiers in their
operation and what does that sound like
to you i mean that's something you could
see kingpin doing for sure it does sound
also like the hand right is it possible
that like stick could be the hand who uh
who reaches out or if it's just like the
fact that it is a hand that we first see
i mean the kingpin definitely had
associations with the hand uh there's
there's lots of connective tissue here
what what's super interesting about this
is that you know we know from black
widow that you know the the red room is
all about grooming children it's all
about growing the the youths and maybe
kingpin found out about that he was like
i want that for myself or like maybe he
has to fight some red room people as
part of his operation or maybe he's
working with the red room and like he's
just like hey let's just find these
girls the best fighting girls to to put
them inside the red room who knows but i
feel like there's going to be some type
of kingpin involvement with the red room
because we do have elena involved and we
do yeah um you know have black widow um
as a factor so yeah there's an argument
that the the hand that uh pinched her
cheek was uh drakov but i just think
drankoff wouldn't be in brooklyn right
here and carrying that much about the
track suits he has like bigger stuff
going on if it is draco i wanna be
pissed i'm gonna keep it real with you
man i
drakov is like not my favorite marvel
villains it is please let it be kingpin
for the love of god please
well there's plenty of evidence that
points in that direction right uh ronin
kills william at the fat man auto repair
i think that is interesting right like
that's their body shop like why would
they name it that like you know you got
bodied at the body shop by the biggest
body of them just kidding oh yeah
now an interesting point here that qazi
warned maya that they don't want uncle
to find out how obsessed she is with
using the gang to hunt ronin meaning
uncle doesn't really care that much
about ronin or doesn't want to tangle
with him and on the other side of it
clint suggested that the real boss of
the tracksuits is not someone you want
to mess with so that he must know who
uncle is exactly he's just not telling
us yet and in past episodes he indicated
that he didn't know how high this goes
the auctioneer said that the ronin
nearly annihilated the head of organized
crime meaning that ronan clint must have
stopped short or reached a kind of
impasse with uncle whoever he is and
that uncle might have some kind of like
agreement with ronan some kind of like
uh uh ceasefire you know like
you don't attack my guys or maybe it's
just that black widow recruited ronan
before he finished that mission of
killing kingpin and kingpin feels a bit
grateful for that you know i really like
that you brought that up because like i
don't know if you've ever played the
spider-man ps4 game but a huge uh part
of that is like kingpin being like i
need to be in this city like the city
needs you to function or else you know
the crime is gonna go even worse so
maybe yeah made a deal it was like hey
you know i could take you down but it's
gonna make more problems for everyone so
i think i've taken down like taking
enough guys out just be cool we're good
i won't show up and then he shows up and
then he has to kill him again because he
broke their deal i like that that's a
really good idea yeah you know that's
like we forget that about kingpin why
he's such a fearsome villain yeah he's a
huge guy and he does just have this
ability just to body slam people and
destroy them just with his hands he's
awesome in his own right
um he's a wide dude but like he has that
connection in new york city he feels a
sense of ownership and protection of it
and everybody else who claims to be a
vigilante or someone who's going to be a
lethal protector or a friendly
neighborhood whatever he's like get out
of my city you're making it worse doing
what you're doing trust me i got the
connections i can i can keep things from
getting worse i am the last line of
defense from the greater madness from
the abyss um now last week we didn't
talk about this in our videos but a lot
of people pointed out that eleanor's
event is held at the same hotel in new
york that was used as the shooting
location of the presidential hotel that
kingpin buys in season three of
daredevil
often in new york they shoot at similar
locations i i didn't think that smoking
gun i do think it is an interesting
parallel though if kingpin does end up
coming into the show oh yeah i mean like
like we said like there was the whole
fat man auto repair easter egg so i just
feel like the show is very much thinking
about locations as really important
parts of the story yeah uh so a lot of
this stuff just seems to be lining up
but everything else just seems to be
like one-way direction it's not a solid
link as batman auto repair
it could point in other directions like
i like the idea that they're in a boxing
gym i i was looking for fog wells
written somewhere on that oh my god
that'd be so cool i didn't see it yet
but uh like i also find it interesting
that armand accused eleanor of aligning
herself with some powerful friend to
grow her empire that armand has his own
powerful friends uh so there's a lot of
big power players in this universe we
should also just like you know point out
that it is interesting that echo had so
many associations with the dragon like
that's kind of her spirit animal her
father said you have to be like the
dragon you have to transition from one
world to another and that's how you grow
your power i thought that was such a
beautiful illustration of how she could
use her deafness as a strength but is it
possible if there's any associations
with the ten rings there because this is
all set in 2007 before the avengers or
iron man got on the picture the ten
rings were uh kind of at the peak of
their power around this time uh i don't
think that was win woo who pinched her
cheek there uh but could there be a link
with the tin rings on this show 100
there's a
ten rings are a massive organization
they got their hands in so many pots and
they're in like the shadows kind of like
hydra they're kind of working because
that's how when who likes to operate so
yeah there's a very huge chance that we
could see some 10 rings involvement here
because we're talking about this is a
gang show christmas gang [ __ ] hooray
is there anyone else in the like i'm
just thinking it could be uncle could be
stick it could be someone associated
with win woo
uh i just think kingpin is like
the most likely option like i'm i know
i'm hedging my bets a little bit here um
i just
to me there's it's hard not to read it
that way oh yeah like i i cannot think
of anybody else if it's not kingpin then
like all of these obvious clues that
they're shoving it to our faces
uh would be just it would just be the
biggest misdirect of all time i just
can't think of anybody else it could be
all right well let's talk about some
more questions we had coming out of this
episode but first we want to thank our
friends at stance socks for sponsoring
this episode underwood socks used to be
the bummer presents you threw to the
side while searching for more fun gifts
on christmas morning but stance has
changed all that with their comfy
colorful gear they make the kind of
socks and underwear you'll be thrilled
to pull out of your stocking stance's
premium line of apparel always comes
correct with color designs innovative
materials and choice fits that are built
to last their all-star collaborator
lineup also sets the brand apart they
have a really cool current
collaborations with brands that new
rockstars fans will enjoy like marvel
star wars batman and pixar there's also
some cool holiday themed socks with
clark griswold the grinch buddy the elf
on them so check out stance.com for all
the latest including several different
subscription options that are sure to
keep your friends and family feeling
great all year round santa's a perfect
gift for every punk and poet on your
list go see for yourself it's easy just
head on over to stats.com and pick out
some styles you think they might like
enjoy the color and comfort of a life
less ordinary with stance also thanks to
helix for sponsoring this episode you
might lose some sleep because you're
staying up late and watching the latest
hawkeye episode but you shouldn't lose
any sleep because of a bad mattress
helix sleep has a quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot even the helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers i have a helix
mattress and i love it the quiz matched
me with a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool the
mattress ships right to your door for
free no need to go to the mattress store
just go to helixsleep.com inside marvel
take their two minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10 year warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep dot com
inside marvel also thanks to bluetooth
because guys there's nothing sexier than
confidence and bluetooth can help give
you that confidence where it counts blue
chew is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you can take them anytime day or night
so you can plan ahead and be ready for
whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
no waiting line the pharmacy bluetooth
tablets are made in the usa and prepared
and shipped direct to your door in a
discreet package so if you could benefit
from some extra confidence when it's
time to perform bluetooth can help and
we've got a special deal for our
listeners to try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code inside marvel at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
inside marvel to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
the show and finally we want to thank
upstart for sponsoring us the one thing
none of us want to be worrying about is
looming specter of a big old credit card
balance upstart can help lift that
burden and help you avoid the debt demon
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funny personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple fixed monthly payment unlike
other lenders upstart looks at more than
just your credit score like your income
and employment history this means they
can offer smarter rates with trusted
partners with a five-minute online rate
check you can see your rate up front for
loans between one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars you can receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com marvel that's
upstart.com marvel don't forget to use
our url to let them know that we sent
you load amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com marvel all
right back to the episode mt i want to
ask you what the hawk is sloan limited
the company that qazi works for
that's a really good question and it's a
huge mystery because like i i really
want to know this as well what we do
know about you know kate's mother is
that she works as part of a security
organization so it's safe to assume that
slow limited is probably one of these um
clients that kate's mom does security
for i have this feeling that eleanor the
the sketchy woman that she is um is
probably using her her security
influence to uh to actually
do anti-security and do crimes um on
behalf of like your kingpins or all
these organizations she's probably
working with organized crime and it's
the perfect front it's like hey if we
have the security people on our side why
not but what's also interesting about
amanda's database is that it's so
expansive that it sort of gives me
project insight vibes a little bit um
because that's
all the whole deal is trying to you know
find people gather information to find
out who to assassinate and i was like
hey eleanor's mom has a little bit too
much information i don't know maybe that
this is like a hydra operation who knows
but what do you think slow it is i don't
i don't know yeah i looked up there
there are some obscure sloanes in the
marvel world there's morris sloan
there's walker sloan that are connected
to uh the spider-man edge of time
there's frederick sloane who was like a
human in a random hulk comic i i think
sloan is just a name that's gonna be
specific to the mcu i think it's a front
company i think it's a shell company uh
and i think it's just kind of the way
that eleanor can put the tracksuits on
the books and that she can fund them to
to do whatever she wants to do you know
i think we're gonna find out through the
paper trail that that sloan is one of
many uh shell companies one of many
fronts that is on the bishop security
payroll and that bishop security is
really like many private security firms
into some shady [ __ ]
and i i think uh i don't think eleanor's
gonna be the one behind it all i
obviously she is partnered with someone
and i am curious that uh our mind might
have suspected it uh i'm just worried
what
jack is getting out of all this i at
first thought that armand didn't trust
eleanor as a partner to zach because he
saw eleanor getting flirty with the
kingpin you know and that
or whoever with uncle is and he knows
what he saw and she's like whatever you
saw and he's like yeah yeah you're
together
but like
this is gross to talk about you know
this is normally the conversation we
have but it's like
jack down with what eleanor is doing is
jack
is is that
is is marvel gonna go there
should we go there is that why people
subscribe to this dope to talk about
things and gross them out and their kids
i'm sorry for saying that
i don't know tony dalton's playing this
so close to the chest i i could see it
going a lot of different ways like so
like just jack being like evil and
working with eleanor is what you're
implying oh i mean i think that's that
goes without saying obviously eleanor
has another more powerful partner in all
this and i'm not saying that has to be
sexual i'm just saying that i don't
think that powerful partner is going to
be jack he's obviously the red herring
for sure for sure like jack is obviously
he's the swordsman he's like pretty much
a good guy in the marvel comics he's
just an [ __ ] so like he's this is the
very much uh the red herring but who is
this partner hmm
yeah it's
jack jealous of that partner or i think
he's just okay with all this i think
he's just being used i think he's
oblivious to everything eleanor is doing
and that he's just being used for his
money or something but he's just he's
too smart i think he's too smart or
maybe like all he wants is that freaking
sword
he's a huge sword stand man straight up
sword stand only cares about his swords
and uh
that's i i honestly i think that this is
his only concern is the swords um
we can
you can take over all of staten island
no no no
i would like to think that him and
eleanor's relationship just started with
her promising swords
and he's just like whatever i'll do
whatever you say you can have my buddy
duffel bag of swords he's like oh you
got this from galaxy's edge you build a
saber it's cool
like we're literally the first meetup
after the the tinder messages she just
brings out the box the bag of swords
this is how our relationship is gonna go
when he goes to the bank like um can you
pay me in sorts
can you cash this in little sorts
i have a check for a million dollars i
don't want money just swords please just
uh all the swords you have in the back
really
let's talk about maya and william what
the hawk is their story was maya born
this way did was there some incident
that caused her to lose her foot i found
that to be a fascinating reveal and i
love that the way they use the the
backpack and the wide shot to just kind
of mask that uh her other foot and then
they reveal it as she's walking up
and then williams seemed to be in some
kind of debt you know he had some kind
of debt that he had to work off are we
going to revisit this or is this the
only flashback we're going to get uh yo
i think we're definitely going to get
more flashbacks um and like when you
this is just a random thing but when you
brought up the gym i was like we're
totally going to see matt murdock kid
matt murdock apparently like at some
point because she does mention like
going to a school with people with
disabilities and like it would just be
weird if we didn't see a child matt
murdock but anyway in regards to myron
williams relationship um and how she
lost her foot i think that there's
probably
you know similar to how you know hawkeye
becomes deaf maybe there was an
explosion and she became deaf and lost
her leg in that explosion when she was a
kid
which is terrible to happen to a kid
that's really sad especially a kid as
adorable as that child actor but you
know it's possible that she just as deaf
because of an accident and then uh
wilson fisk the other will in her life
was just like hey i'll help you out if
you do cry and you're like sure why not
um but yeah what do you think yeah it's
interesting we know very little about
this era of mcu history before 2008
before the first iron man right chung
chi started to explore it a little bit
with the tin rings in china uh black
widow revisited around this time i
believe is when uh uh natasha targeted
drakov and thought that she killed him
and his daughter um yeah i i think that
there's gonna be an additional flashback
or some other context i think uh zach
mclaren is uh signed up for two episodes
this season so hopefully we'll have some
other kind of flashback to give that
context i think
her relationship with uncle is all tied
in with her current condition her mom's
not in the picture right so like we we
have questions about what happened to
the mom uh was the mom killed and then
that's why william kind of feels
indebted is that gonna be how echo is
kind of flipped right like she finds out
that the organization she was part of i
think that's gonna be kate's learning
curve this this season is both of these
young women find out that they're part
of very corrupt screwed up organizations
that groom them that force them on this
path that they might not have chosen
otherwise and they both lost a parent at
a young age as a result of those
criminal connections and i think that
might be how they're able to extract
themselves from that uh as kate learns a
deeper truth or kate learns the deeper
truth and maya learns a deeper truth
about why they are the way they are and
uh they feel bitter about that
and then kate and maya and yelena all
form a cool team of badass girls who
fight crime together let's make it
happen i just want to see a girl team so
badly it'd be so great let's um talk
about these trick arrows so when did
clint get this pim arrow and these other
trick arrows when did he build this
collection dude i freaking this is
literally hands down my favorite moment
of the entire episode i love the pimero
and it really makes me like happy to
think that hank pym is playing nice and
he's just like all right i'll just share
a little bit of my tech because there is
the whole ass pym logo on the tip which
is yeah which is basically says that
this was sanctioned by hank pym hank
stamped it yeah and so it's just it's so
cool seeing that he's just like all
right the avenge i'm basically an
avenger now this is just my life um and
so i just i'm part i'm he's probably
making tech for all the other avengers
not just hawkeye which is really
interesting so i would love to see more
pink pemtech being integrated much like
star jack was integrated right it kind
of sounds like pym might have supplanted
stark as the new tinkerer for the
avengers or whoever is now representing
the avengers it's just fascinating to
see his name on there it makes us wonder
when this happened it must have been
after end game right because hank and
scott were missing throughout the blip
uh before that they were on house arrest
right after civil war up until up until
the blip so there's some kind of period
in the years after end game where like
hank pym is hooking up these other
ex-avengers or you know retired avengers
with this gear but i found it
interesting that most of the trick
arrows with the exception of the um
explosive one a lot of them were
non-lethal you know like there's like
this purple gas
that what did not knock them out like
they kind of went
all right right now that's too much
purple
also purple putty like purple is a weird
recurring color with these but it also
it's the color of hawkeye so that might
have just been a production design
choice yeah this weird like a suction
cup one that we saw use we had the the
wire one that grabbed all the christmas
trees like it felt kind of like home
alone like make the bad guys
to them to sticky
them so true i just like that clint like
after being ronin figured let's just get
more creative with these arrows so that
i have other strategies i can use other
than just
putting an arrow through someone's
throat oh yeah cause like you know
during that diner scene like again he's
felt it seems like he's super remorseful
about his time as ronan he doesn't want
to kill anymore so he's probably just
like all right suction arrow time and
usb time
hit him with the u.s beer why didn't
that go through the tracksuit's body the
angle she shot at it bounced off him
usbs if you stick this in hard enough
into someone's
someone's chest at like that at the rate
and arrow it's gonna like go through
their shirt and skin and plug into them
it's gonna hurt it's not gonna go point
like that guy is made of something
strong maybe he just has strong pectoral
muscles he's just like hey usb can't
pierce me that already happened once to
me before never again i'll never be
pierced by a usb arrow again i'm working
on it you see like uh using the the way
that like kingpin just kind of stuff can
bounce off kingpin is he using the same
pilates method that i think so let's
talk about the bishop lineage real
quickly she talked about how her great
great great great grandfather
constructed this home why do you think
it was so important for eleanor to
reconstruct their penthouse from 2012
after that building seemed to get
wrecked as opposed to moving to just any
other you know
multi-million dollar penthouse in the
midtown area is something in that
building that uh kate and eleanor bishop
or specifically eleanor bishop doesn't
want other people moving in on
that's actually a really good thought
and maybe it has something to do with
the watch because like maybe there's
something in that building that the
watch can get access to
and eleanor is just sort of just like
all right i have i found this like i
don't know safe or whatever lock box i'm
gonna stay here until i can find the
missing piece there has to be some type
of connection or something there that
eleanor finds um significance so i'm
wondering what that is what do you think
yeah i think it's just uh gets to the
question of real estate in the manhattan
area like they brought up last episode
that tony sold
stark avengers tower to someone in a
roundabout way i feel like a connection
to wilson fisk who real estate in
manhattan is everything that's the whole
game block by block you know it's his
city he thinks he can do better with it
i think the fact that they don't want
other people to come in and buy that
penthouse means that this is like some
kind of historic thing and the the
bishop family has a historic connection
to this turf and that we saw in the
graveyard russell bishop a headstone in
the background
in focused enough that we could make out
the name russell i i don't think russell
was a great great great grandfather that
doesn't sound like a
17th century
uh name did you have a lot of wrestles
back then i don't know i think we're
gonna learn more about uh the bishop
family lineage uh with the swords with
uh
with who derek really was and what he
was actually trying to do kate kind of
paints it interesting like my father was
just trying to help people and i don't
think that's the case i i think we're
gonna find out that her father was kind
of a dirt bag or just mixed up with some
bad people
yeah her father definitely has some
secrets or something that eleanor is
trying to exploit so i'm very interested
to see what he's all about well that is
it for this episode of inside marvel
we're gonna be back next week with our
reaction to episode four
uh which i believe will be no it'll just
be another uh episode that you know uh
but every episode has like revealed more
and more uh trentran said that episode
five is her favorite of the series but i
think the finale of episode four it's
gonna be like with uh loki right the
finale of episode four he wakes up in
the void and he sees the alternate
loki's i think we're gonna get some
twists at the end of that episode that
makes episode five a stunner
alligator hawkeye
yeah
that'd be amazing every episode four
just ends with an alligator variant of
whatever
well don't forget to check out our many
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at ea boss follow mt at
mastertainment follow new rockstar
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast thank you for watching
and we'll close with our second favorite
moment of the episode
you